what did I say was actually the best
shot vision what did I describe is crazy
oh I think that's the bricks oh come on
hmm that was crazy the scenes I mean I
think you're seeing Little Mix I'm being
on the red carpet oh the red carpet was
the most craziest bit because my friend
was on the wrong side of the car so he's
got up on the side I meant to go and
everyone screamed for him first
perfect and then it was quiet and then
when I came out it was always room yeah
I say my sister is but you know I call
my sister I'm just gonna say it again
actually no Jesse because that is what
we actually named Macomber sometimes I
wish I was an octopus it has something
to do with eight legs so I could slap
eight people at once
there's definitely a lot of people not
wanting to slap at times I understand it
was actually the best shot I'm assuming
that's that two words it's definitely
not EastEnders
I've got that that was official what did
I say was my favorite animal this is
gonna be awkward if it's not a derocker
it's a jerk-off indeed I love them yep I
love them I thought I would take this
time to say that my mom loves you a lot
she tries to take this picture of you
when we was at my uncle Depp and sure
this is she caught who did my mom trying
get off oh definitely not storms he yeah
she loves him do you know what it's so
unfortunate because it's just seemed
like every any time that she's not free
I always see him boy mom you got make it
so free of it now
most probably giving my pick one I'm
super excited to announce our new
partnership with Jamie Oliver what this
man replied to this to you from
desperate Sutton about changes must be
or Moodle well hope in Tesco
I just think from Charlie just tried to
destroy fun habits of eating good food
that that sweets now and come into
schools and I reckon all school dinners
nearly finished just saying what was my
reply to my mom I think I said something
like I'm definitely coming home and I'm
not going back
mom I'm not going back to university and
I'm not moving
sorry love you I think it's time I leave
her what did I say was one of the best
games this must be an awesome action
I must have been bored I remember
playing out in that promise me it was
just like penguins and you should just
run wrong there in two different places
make friends and stuff like that just
dress up your penguin your this is Rams
and this is back in time Rome of lad
Bible came back Syria